our Series a more perfect union aimed to
show that what unites us as Americans is
far greater than what divides us on
Thanksgiving we reflect on the things
and the people for which we are grateful
in honor of this tradition we asked
Amanda Gorman the inaugural youth poet
laureate of the United States to write a
poem about what the holiday means to her
the 20 year old is a junior at Harvard
University and that is where she
performed her composition the Republic
gives thanks in 1863 deep in the civil
wars magnitude Abraham Lincoln declared
a day of gratitude shared by one heart
and a one voice of America
a proclamation for a nation in a
nightmare
this Thanksgiving dared Americans to
chime their things at a time when many
believes they had no thanks to give yet
is this quirky day now all about Turkey
about a plate full of food or is it
about being grateful in more than just
attitude the Iroquois remind us with one
mind to find the words that come before
all else because to give things is to
live it it's not just in speech but in
each of our daily actions it's reaching
across divisions towards a vision of a
long strong house and table where were
able to gather together
if we dream past pill guns in the mast
of the Mayflower it may empower us to
bravely learn from the people of the
first lights to return to Lincoln's
fight to furnish or mites by uniting
around any piece of peace no matter how
small
we still hear all of these first
teachers called by the will of those
still here on this earth like the
Wampanoag who show us the worthiest way
to give thanks for our blessings isn't
to hug them but to give them away
[Music]
it is then full of this feeling that
healing can begin because maybe to be
American is to be akin to a courageous
hope the trust that even if just for a
moment we can we must close rank as
people one heart one voice one mind
created equal like two vessels meeting
at a riverbank anew under the skies
greeting of a bright
blank blue you'll begin beside the
people who flank you we come to these
words before and above all dreams saying
with more love and restore the meaning
thank you that was stunning I had an
opportunity she was here in the
broadcast Center and with our producer
Carrie Cleveland who produced an
incredibly beautiful piece
she's so impressive there's an energy
that was coming off for her that you
know she's we're gonna be hearing about
her not just the words the delivery so
power if I could bottle like five
percent of that peaceful finding a piece
within peace yeah my husband sent me a
text said I love her yeah we do indeed
that was great thank you Kara